au sol et mentale juste à ces vignes
life box
harry potter saga légendaire écrite par
jk rowling est paru à partir de 1997 en
livre évidemment cette saga sera
réadapté en film et accroître ralph
succès phénoménal de la série de 2001 à
je suis un réel fans d'harry potter
pourtant j'admets n'avoir jamais lu les
livres
l'émotion et les pics sont présents et
c'est ce que j'aime avant tout dans les
films que cela soit la bande-son
l'histoire les acteurs tout est
important et tout ceci me font adoré
cette saga
je ne pense pas avoir besoin de vous
résumer harry potter de pardies sa
célébrité mais énormément de mystère
tourne autour de cette saga magique sans
faire de jeu de mots
l'histoire est très complète et en même
temps peut nous laisse imaginer beaucoup
de théories qu énormément de fans ont su
exploiter et en voici trois que je vous
propose
drago malefoy y est un personnage
vraiment très peu apprécié de par le
fait qu'il soit prétentieux et par son
comportement
l'histoire de drague aussi parallèlement
celle de harry car ils grandissent
ensemble dans la même histoire
drago est même considéré un peu comme le
soi-disant rival de harry potter dans
les débuts de la saga mais nous en
savons peu sur drago il est mal dans sa
peau arrogant il épiait trente ans que
mangemorts et se dégonflent eux face à
ses responsabilités et bien ainsi drago
malefoy était en fait un loup garou
cette théorie est un petit peu simplette
mais je la trouve tout de même
intéressante
il est dit que lorsque voldemort est
déçu de ses mangemorts il les punis en
faisant mordre leurs enfants par fenrir
le loup garou ce qu'ils transmettraient
la maladie lycanthropique lucius malefoy
est un mangemort obéissant à voldemort
cependant c'est un fuyard est un lâche
il a énormément déçu voldemort se serait
pourquoi drago se serait fait mordre
comment pouvons-nous le remarquer je
vais beaucoup inspiré du film étant la
seule source que je connais sur le bout
des doigts d'harry potter du film à 1,4
drago est un enfant plutôt heureux dans
sa partie et réprime les autres il est
très prétentieux et n'hésite pas à
montrer qu'il fait partie de la classe
des gens aisés
cependant suite au retour du seigneur
des ténèbres dans harry potter 4
voldemort en appelant ses mangemorts
montre bien qu'il est très déçu que ceci
n'est pas cherché à le retrouver
dont lucius suite à cela à partir de
l'opus 5 l'ordre du phénix drago devient
quelqu'un de totalement différent et
très embarrassé mal dans sa peau et se
dégonflent énormément la théorie du loup
garou montrerait alors que drago a
changé et est devenu comme ça à cause de
sa maladie lycanthropique
cette théorie est vraiment ma préférée
de l'univers harry potter j'espère
qu'elle en sera de même pour vous tout
le monde connaît le compte des trois
frères dans harry potter histoire très
célèbre qui façonnera le dernier opus
et bien si ce conte des trois frères se
réaliser réellement dans l'histoire
d'après le conte la mort a offert à
trois frères 3 artefacts la baguette de
sureau aux frères désirant le pouvoir
lapierre de résurrection aux frères
désirant ramener son épouse décédée et
la cape d'invisibilité aux frères désir
en échappée et humilié la mort le 1er
frères se fera de nombreux ennemis à
cause de cette baguette et se fera tuer
le second verra sa compagne ressuscité
mais restera simplement un fantôme
donc il se suicidera puis le dernier
évitera la mort toute sa vie avant
vieillard doté sa cape et de
l'accueillir à bras ouverts
ce conte pourrait être associé à quatre
personnages du film
voldemort severus rogue harry potter et
albus dumbledore
pourquoi ces personnages sont quatre
piliers principaux de la saga et chaque
description correspond un personnage du
conte pour commencer voldemort souhaite
posséder le pouvoir absolu et
l'immortalité
il a soif de grandeur il possédera la
baguette de sureau par la suite et moore
a tué de la main de harry potter
ensuite c'est vrai c'est quelqu'un de
très spécial dans harry potter
il joue le rôle d'un agent double et ne
vit que par amour pour lily la défunte
mère de harry potter
cependant il se fera tuer à son tour
puis harry potter il possède la cape
d'invisibilité a toujours survécu à la
mort qui ne pu l'apprendre jusqu'au jour
où il affronte son destin et se laisse
tuer par voldemort dans la forêt
interdite
il meurt et retrouve la mort comme un
vieil ami bien évidemment je parle de
dumbledore
c'est le pilier de cette théorie albus
dumbledore serait la mort en personne
déjà par le fait qu'il retrouve harry
potter comme un vieil ami dans la mort
puis car ils possèdent les reliques de
la mort
il fut le propriétaire de la baguette de
sureau il a légué la pierre de
résurrection à harry kullas cape
d'invisibilité
ce n'est pas montré dans le film par qui
elle est offerte mais je suppose
sincèrement qu'elle est donnée par
dumbledore et harry pour le protéger de
la mort justement je trouve vraiment
cette théorie excellente et je trouve
qu'elle colle vraiment aux personnages
ce sous-entendu caché est vraiment très
intéressant
pour finir j'aimerais vous parler d'une
petite théorie que je trouve plutôt
sympathique elle relève de l'historique
d'après cette théorie le destin de fred
et george était prédestiné arriver
pourquoi cette histoire se base sur les
rois et reines britannique qui
gouvernait le pays
il faut savoir avant tout que l'humain
pour créer du contenu s'inspire toujours
de quelque chose ou quelqu'un de façon
plus ou moins éloquentes
nous en avons l'exemple avec star wars à
propos de l' empire qui s'inspire du
régime nazi ou bien les chimères de
final fantasy qui s'inspire de
mythologie et de dieu est bien ici c'est
pareil qui nous dit que jk rowling ne
serait pas inspiré de l'histoire
britannique pour créer harry potter
après tout elle est anglaise
enfin rentrons directement dans la
théorie les noms de la famille weasley à
part ron allez savoir pourquoi sont
inspirés de la famille royale et fred et
george en font partie dans les films
nous savons que george a eu un terrible
accident lors du transfert d' harry et
qu'il était gravement blessé à l'oreille
à partir de ce moment il était donc sûr
et certain que fred allait mourir
pourquoi dans l'histoire royale
britannique il est dit que le roi george
iii était sourd d'une oreille nous
pouvons relier sa à l'accident de
georges et que du coup il était devenu
roi à cause de la mort prématurée du
prince frederik c'est clair je pense le
roi george iii est associé à georges et
le prince frederik à fred les noms sont
les mêmes
est-ce que jk rowling a fait exprès de
les appeler comme ça que george est un
accident comme par hasard à l'oreille et
que fred meurt dans le dernier opus
rien n'a été confirmé mais je pense que
c'est réellement évitant le hasard n'est
pas permis sur ce genre d'histoire
qu'en pensez vous j'aimerais avoir vos
réactions c'est important pour moi je
vous souhaite de boire un bon jus de
citrouille et je vous dis à bientôt
c'était un gorille